one of my my main goals was to get back
in the england fold
you know i'm just focused on showing
gareth what person i am now and you know
what
you know i can bring to his team just on
the pitch as well
hi i'm luke shaw and this is what it
takes for sport bible
[Music]
i i honestly i actually thought i looked
good then as well with that air but
yeah and i was really close with with
proxy and
obviously i think we were just both at
the training camp then
probably both feeling ourselves because
i'm pouting so i must have
been feeling summoned but um me and
palsy we come through i think it was the
under
nines and under eights together and we
were with each other ever since
you know he got fast tracked to the
first team a bit before me but
you know i made sort of friendships for
sort of life
my debut um
this is obviously my first 90 minutes
for um southampton i remember there
being the time where i thought i'm i'm
not getting any game timer
you know i don't know if this is the
right thing for me you know i stuck by
it and
you know i think i i played a game and
literally
the next sort of six months i was
fast-tracked into
you know the first team and you know i
didn't look back
my mom and dad they were definitely at
that game of course it was a very proud
moment for me but
also a very proud moment for them for
you know the sacrifices that not just i
made but but they made so many for me to
to get to where i was
you know at that point you know
pochettino
i feel like he took took my game to
another level and
you know i think a lot of the way i play
now and you know
how i am as a person i think a lot of
that is down to him i think
you know for me he he's one of the best
managers in the world
um you know not just tactically but but
as a man manager as well he's
he's absolutely brilliant right i
i remember this so easily because
it was my debut um with roy hodgson the
manager at the time
um i think there was a picture of me on
the phone
had a little tear in my eye i think that
was when i had rang my family to
to tell them that i was in in the squad
for the first time and
i don't think i've ever been so nervous
in my life i think one once i was on the
pitch
you know the nerves go and you know i
didn't look back i just wanted more and
i felt there was a little bit of a
chance to
to get the england call up and you know
i just pushed myself even harder to
to be able to get that so obviously this
is my um
my debut for for manchester united um
you know i didn't realize how big it was
until i actually got to the club
and nowadays if i was to give advice
for a young player to be going to a
massive club i think it's best to just
stay on social media platforms and
you know just focus on yourself focus on
you know why you're there
why they've signed you and just focus on
getting better and you know ignoring
everything outside of football and
for me and my family it was always
important that you know we kept that
belief that
you know keep pushing and keep fighting
and you know one day you'll be able to
show people why
you know why i'm there um
probably yeah one of the the lowest
points
in my career i think i think it was my
first
champions league game you know after a
tough year first year sort of at united
i think i was
devastated the fact that that i knew
that it was going to be a long time out
and
mentally sometimes you know i was
struggling a lot
like i said with that word resilience
that you know i didn't give in you know
i kept going
and i always looked to that sort of you
know goal that
you know just think about the finish
line and the finish line was was of
course for me to be back out doing what
i love and
i'm playing for for manchester united
i'm not too sure when when this was i
don't know if it was when we lost three
nil
i think if it was it was at the point
when
he had come up to me and you know said
how well i played
um in that game and you know he was that
he was happy with my performance
so how do you describe your relationship
with jose how did you develop
under him as a player and a person it
was
sort of a mixed relationship really i
think
a lot of things you know that happened
between us too i don't think
you know sometimes he went about in the
right way um
and i think a lot of people would agree
with that at the club
people you know know our relationship
wasn't the best i think it was quite
easy to
to probably see that on the outside but
i think you know one thing that
you know josie did do and you know that
was made me
you know mentally much more stronger i
would probably say mental strength is
you know what i would describe the sort
of period
under jose mourinho
i think the difference in the the two
pictures that we've just had before
is lovely it's clear to see obviously
very happy
um smiling um of course it's a massive
honor to
to win that award um ollie just showed
his his belief and
confidence in me and he made me feel
feel like i was a part of the team
you know and i think that was the
difference i think i felt a part of the
team volley
when you know maybe with josie i didn't
yeah i'd say hard work and and
dedication
um i think like i said i always believed
that
you know good times were coming and i
stuck in dug deep
you know went through a lot but you know
come out better on the other side
one of my my main goals was to get back
in the england fold
and i think i really of course you know
remembered my times of playing for
england and
like i said i i really loved every
minute of it and
i really wanted to be a part of that and
i think you know i just kept my head
down worked hard
um you know and and just sort of let my
football do the talking
you know at the club under josie i think
things weren't
you know weren't going well um i think
mentally
you know things wasn't going well you
know i was struggling to get game time
and
you know picking up little niggly
injuries and i think you know at times
you know when i was getting called up
and you know gareth was obviously
showing
showing his faith in me i think
sometimes i pulled out of camps
you know that when i sort of think back
to it it was
you know massive regrets and you know i
thought about it a lot but
that's in the past now and you know i'm
just focused on
showing gareth what person i am now and
you know what
you know i can bring to his team just on
the pitch as well
there's been easily times where people
have thought that you know that was the
end of the road
for england but i think i always sort of
had that like i said belief
you know and that never give up attitude
that you know one day i can you know
fight my way back into you know that
squad and
i've still got a lot more to do but you
know
i'm going in the right direction and you
know i just need to keep doing what i'm
doing and
you know see what happens from there
[Music]
i'm luke shaw and that was what it takes
for sport bible
i was so obsessed with um sport cricket
and particularly football that my
final report from my head master said
spends way too much time in football
he'll never make a living at that